well first of all no one wants to go on
strike strikes The Last Resort and
teachers and support staff who are also
balloting don't want to walk away from
the classroom they know the job they did
during the pandemic educating children
either in person or remotely you know
Reinventing their practice so that they
could teach online with no with no
training or support to do that so they
know and they've worked really hard to
keep children in education that when you
get teachers balloting for strike action
that is a sign of desperation and the
desperation is caused by this we have
schools which are crumbling uh the
biggest risk that the dfae has on their
risk register is a risk of life and limb
because of unsafe school buildings we
have a profession where the teachers
work the most unpaid overtime of any
profession and where we have 40 of them
leaving within 10 years a third leaving
within five years and the teacher
training figures come out today the
number of teachers government we think
there will be less than half the
government's targets of teachers
training so what that means is that
teachers in work have to work so much
harder
for parents and for pupils they're
seeing lessons being taught by teachers
who aren't qualified in the subject
they're teaching increasing use of cover
teachers and Supply teachers because the
leaders are doing everything they can to
get teachers in the classroom so the
service is on its knees and when
teachers vote to go on strike they do
that as a last resort and as a cry for
help because there is nowhere else they
can go if we're going to stop this
Exodus of teachers from the profession
which really affects education standards
because if you're being taught by a
teacher who's not qualified in the
subject they can't however hard they
work do the same job as a teacher who is
qualified then education standards
suffer and this country isn't going to
get the growth it needs if it starves
education resources